all right I like to start with some bad
news and this is
important no one wants to hear anything
you have to say unless you give them a
reason to listen I'm going to say that
again because I want to be really clear
and because I don't think anyone really
believes it no one wants to hear
anything you have to say unless you give
them a reason to listen I tell you this
because I meet people all the time
people who stand on stages who hold
microphones who stand in conference
rooms who conduct All Hands CEOs vice
presidents entrepreneurs everyone they
seem to believe that because the
spotlight is on them or they hold some
high position in the organization people
are listening to them when they speak
when in truth no one wants to hear
anything you have to say unless you give
them a reason to listen it's crazy but
true that that people assume attention
they assume that because they are
standing and speaking that other people
are attending to them when we know this
is not true I know that right now it's
not true I know that it is entirely
possible for you right now to allow your
mind to wander to some to-do list you
have today or to look at your computer
screen or to take another bite of your
cereal it is so easy to stop listening
to the person who is speaking so as a
speaker a Storyteller someone who's
trying to communicate in this world it
is essential that you believe in your
bones that no one wants to hear anything
you have to say unless you give them a
reason to listen the sooner you believe
this the better you're going to be every
single time I take a stage whether it's
to tell a story or speak to a class of
10-year-olds or speak to a bunch of
Executives in a boardroom I believe in
all my heart that no one wants to hear
anything I have to say say and therefore
I must be
relentless in my attempts to engage and
hold my audience's attention I want you
to do the same I want you to be
relentless in the strategies I'm going
to teach you to engage your audience to
hold their attention to keep them
wondering to keep them obsessed with the
words that you speak but that's only
going to happen if you truly believe
that no one wants to hear anything you
have to say unless you give them a
reason to listen please let this be your
guidepost moving forward let this be the
Mantra that runs through your mind no
one wants to hear anything you have to
say unless you give them a reason to
listen
[Music]